So let's look at the problem of aliasing
in the virtual index physical tag
caches.
This is a virtual address.
And the way we access the cache is
these are the offset bits, this will
be our index bits, and this will be the
tag if we use this to access the cache.
In a virtual index cache,
we use the index part of the address.
From the virtual address, the rest
comes from the physical address.
But how do we form the physical address?
Well some lower bits of the virtual
address will be the page offset.
The rest will be the page number.
And now remember that the page
number gets translated
to become the frame number
in the physical address.
While the page offs just goes and
becomes the least significant
base of the physically address.
And in a virtually indexed, physically
tagged cache, our tag comes from here,
but our index came from from here, so
that we could begin the access quickly.
The thing to note is that the index
bits are relatively close to
the least significant bit
of the virtual address, and
that the page offset
has a number of bits.
So for a small cache it can happen
that the index bits that we use
all come from the page offset,
which means they are the same as if we
took them from the physical address.
So, although we are indexing
using the virtual address,
in reality, we are actually using
the same index that we would be using
if we were using the physical address.
Which means, there will be no aliasing.
How is there no aliasing?
Well, because the virtual pages, that
have different page numbers that map to
the same frame number,
can only differ in the page number, but
they have to have the same offsets for
the same data.
And because only the offset matters for
the index if the index
is low enough here.
What happens here is, pretty much,
all of the data that can possibly
be in the same place in the physical
memory has to be in the same set,
because the index is determined only
from the part that has to be the same.
So we have that there is no aliasing
if all of the index bits that we
use came from the page offset.
Because really those are the same
index bits that would
come from the physical address if
we had the physical index cache.
We like this very much, but the cache
has to be small enough to do this.
So for example, if we have a 4 kilobyte
page, we will have a 12-bit page offset.
If our cache is a 32 byte block,
it has a 5-bit block offset here.
That means that the index,
which still needs to fit in the 12
bits of the page offset,
can only have 7 bits, so
we can only have 128 sets in this cache,
which limits its size.
If we have more sets than this,
then some of the index bits
here come from the page number.
And that changes when we have
the frame number, so it can easily be
that the different these bits here end
up mapping to the same frame number,
which we don't want because that
means that multiple sets in the cache
could have the same actual data, which
is bad because we cannot find it then.